[Música]
un año
365 días ya cumplen 4 dirigentes
políticos o líderes opositores de haber
sido detenidos por el gobierno del
presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
estamos hablando de félix en maradiaga
juan sebastián chamorro violeta granera
y josé adán aguerrí quienes han estado
privados de su libertad sin garantías
justas sin garantías apegadas a la ley
sin visitas de sus familiares y según
indican ellos mismos sus familiares en
condiciones deplorables
todos fueron sometidos a un juicio
rápido de solamente siete jornadas a su
término recibieron una condena de 13
años de cárcel cada uno mientras que
violeta granera fue sentenciada a ocho
años de prisión todos fueron condenados
por el supuesto delito de conspiración
para el menoscabo a la integridad
nacional ellos son solamente cuatro de
un grupo de cerca de 180 personas que
son presas políticas en nicaragua
recientemente la corte interamericana de
los derechos humanos ordenó al gobierno
del presidente daniel ortega y de su
esposa rosario murillo la liberación de
un grupo inicial de nueve presos
políticos también instó al gobierno a
tomar medidas para poder garantizar su
integridad física los familiares piden
la reanudación de un diálogo nacional
con la mediación de la iglesia
nicaragüense que tan factible es un
escenario para ese diálogo nacional que
tan factible es el escenario político en
ese país para que esto se lleve a cabo
cuando ha habido ya dos intentos
fallidos que tal está el escenario
político para esas elecciones regionales
que están previstas en nicaragua para
final de este año
y de las demás fuerzas opositoras porque
no hay unión y otra pregunta que surge a
nivel económico han impactado las
sanciones internacionales al gobierno de
daniel ortega pues todas estas preguntas
trataremos de analizarlas con nuestros
invitados para el programa de hoy vamos
a estar conversando con tiziano breda él
es analista para centroamérica del
international crisis group él se conecta
desde la ciudad de guatemala más
adelante les presentaré a nuestro
siguiente invitado que estamos tratando
de solucionar un tema técnico para
poderlo conectar a esta conversación les
pido disculpas ustedes saben esto pasa
en estas transmisiones en vivo y pues
más adelante se va a incorporar a esta a
este análisis con nuestro invitado desde
ciudad de guatemala pero ustedes también
nuestros televidentes hacen parte de
esta conversación estamos a través de
diferentes redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook también en
instagram en twitter pueden encontrar
también nuestra señal de streaming en
youtube nos encuentran como arroba
france24
bajo ese y también arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo la
etiqueta es numeral del debate efe 24
para que dejen sus y sus preguntas
comienzo entonces con tiziano en la
ciudad de guatemala la capital
guatemalteca tiziano muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa y me
gusta siempre poner como punto de
partida esta primera pregunta que es
para abrir el debate para conocer un
poco las posiciones que tienen los
invitados ya lo mencionaba yo un año de
detención de estos dirigentes políticos
o dirigentes sociales la situación en
nicaragua tal parece que no mejora en
términos democráticos al contrario se ha
venido deteriorando aún más cuáles son
sus impresiones del estado democrático
de este país del estado de la política
de este país y del gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega
bueno muchas gracias santiago por la
habitación es un placer y buenas tardes
a los televidentes
creo que ortega el gobierno de ortega y
la vice presidente rotario murillo ha
sorprendido a varios observadores tanto
nacionales como internacionales
que creíamos que digamos esta escalada
represiva que se dio antes de las
elecciones y que justamente mencionaba
con algunos dirigentes políticos que
cumplen un año y muchos más que vendrán
de los alrededor de 40 que fueron
detenidos incluso siete aspirantes a la
presidencia en las elecciones generales
del año pasado de noviembre de 2021
y todo lo que creíamos que digamos que
esta escalada precisamente es el
propósito de asegurar una reelección y
después de ese momento
hubiéramos visto una algunas aperturas
algún intento de recomponer la
figura la imagen del presidente alguna
concesión a nivel nacional e
internacional en cambio estamos viendo
una radicalización cada vez más marcada
de esta represión de
detenciones que siguen habiendo
regularmente de opositores políticos
incluso algunos que ya habían estado en
las cárceles a la altura de las
protestas de 2018 estamos viendo la
cancelación de personerías jurídicas de
centenares de organizaciones de la
sociedad civil de ongs que trabajan en
los más diferentes temas y cruces en
acción salud etcétera
incluso estamos viendo un aumento de los
ataques contra la iglesia católica o sea
que realmente
está radicalizando el gobierno y no
parece estar dispuesto a abrir a ninguna
apertura
tiziano en ese orden de ideas y con este
panorama que usted nos muestra
brevemente sobre nicaragua que tan
deteriorada hasta entonces la
institucionalidad del estado
nicaragüense
a esta altura tras estos prácticamente
cinco años de gobierno ortega haciendo
un poco de balance de lo que teníamos al
principio de la gestión orteguista a lo
que hemos visto con esta radicalización
que ha habido en los últimos años
bueno yo miraría un poco más atrás de
los últimos cinco años ortega regresó al
poder en 2007 después de ganar
legítimamente las elecciones de 2006
jugando con la descomposición y las
divisiones que ya en esa época habían en
las fuerzas liberales
desde entonces ha empezado un proceso
paulatino de desmantelamiento de los
contrapesos democráticos de
concentración del poder y de cooptación
básicamente de la institucionalidad y
esto ha venido
consolidándose claramente poco a poco y
ha venido expresando digamos todas la
peligrosidad de una concentración de
poder de este nivel
a raíz de las protestas que en 2018
estallaron y que precisamente
la represión que se dio a estas
protestas pues mostró con toda su
fortaleza la el control que la pareja
presidencial tiene sobre el el asamblea
legislativa sobre de perdonarles
nacional sobre el aparato judicial sobre
las fuerzas de seguridad
y con las elecciones recientes sobre
también las instituciones electorales
entonces realmente es posiblemente la
situación más crítica en cuanto a
control y concentración del poder
en un estado digamos en asia tivo en
tiziano más allá de esta concentración
de poder que ya usted nos explica de los
diferentes entes del estado nicaragüense
donde pues sólo por nombrar alguno el
congreso el parlamento nicaragüense pues
está prácticamente con mayoría de los
sandinistas quien mantiene ortega en el
poder quien mantiene a quien beneficia
que el presidente daniel ortega con
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
con esta represión con el silencio de la
prensa con enviar a la cárcel sin
unos juicios propios de la ley
nicaragüense envía a los ex candidatos
que se van a enfrentar a él en las urnas
hay varios factores creo yo en primer
lugar bueno antes de 2018 que ortega
había sabido establecer relaciones
funcionales
pragmáticas y queremos decirlo con
sectores como la iglesia católica y el
sector privado que le habían permitido
gobernar incluso con ciertos niveles de
simpatía a raíz de lo que ocurrió en
2018 claramente estos estas relaciones
se inclinaron se rompieron y
y vemos cada vez más la necesidad de
precisamente imponer esta represión este
estado policial de facto este cierre de
los espacios para precisamente evitar
que estas crecientes quizás malhumores
en la sociedad nicaragüenses pues se
puedan convertir nuevamente en un
movimiento de protesta muy amplio no hay
que pero digamos dejar de lado de que al
menos en cualquier encuesta que ha
salido en los últimos cuatro años
nunca el digamos el nivel de simpatía o
de apoyo al gobierno ha bajado a menos
del 20 por ciento más o menos de los
encuestados en las más diferentes
encuestas entonces estamos hablando de
que todas fueron una buena parte de la
población que todavía sigue apegada a lo
que es el digamos de sentimiento
revolucionario y que ve de manera quizás
favorable este gobierno y el otro
elemento creo yo es que hay una buena
parte de la población que simplemente no
ve alternativa que no le interesa tanto
el tema político y que esta disolución
nada con eso movimientos que surgieron a
raíz de la protesta de 2018 y que por
años no lograron representar fielmente
los sentimientos de la población y en
cambio estuvieron envueltos en lucha de
poder de egos de intereses políticos
no por último hay que también decir que
eventualmente el gobierno de todas forma
ha logrado recuperar cierta
estabilidad económica así que si
queremos
llamarla actualmente en dos años de la
protesta hubo una contracción muy fuerte
pero todos esos sectores empresariales
de la banca del agro de exportaciones de
café de oro etcétera pues están viviendo
un momento
bastante bueno a pesar de toda la
situación política y por lo tanto ven
con
alguna suspicacia un digamos un posible
cambio político por sectores que han
demostrado ser bastante desordenados
tiziano ya vamos a analizar el tema
económico y las sanciones a nivel
internacional porque varios factores ahí
que están en juego y tal parece que el
resultado al final del día el resultado
que esperaba la comunidad internacional
con esas sanciones no ha sido el
esperado y pues como usted lo dice la
economía nicaragüense en cierta forma se
ha sostenido o se ha recuperado después
de esa contracción que tuvo a raíz de
las protestas y seguimos intentando
solucionar el tema técnico para conectar
a nuestro otro invitado que está en la
ciudad de washington para que también
haga parte de este debate para conocer
otro punto de vista me confirma ya desde
el control que ya está conectado con
nosotros entonces le di la bienvenida a
josé miguel vivanco el ex ex director
para las américas de human right watch
como les decía se conecta desde la
capital de eeuu
el señor vivanco muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros bueno parece que ya
solucionamos el tema técnico y lo vamos
a tener por lo menos por vía telefónica
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa
lo pongo un poco al tanto de lo que
hemos hablado con tiziano hemos hecho un
panorama rápido de cómo está la
situación en nicaragua y de esa alerta
que hay por parte de la comunidad
internacional en torno al deterioro de
la democracia ahora que se cumple un año
del arresto de cuatro dirigentes
políticos que aspiraban a ser candidatos
a la presidencia en los comicios del año
pasado como punto de partida le planteó
entonces la misma pregunta su panorama
general del país de la situación
política de la imagen de ortega de este
deterioro democrático y de la situación
de la institucionalidad nicaragüense
a ver la situación no puede ser peor
está
perfectamente consolidada esta dictadura
en nicaragua en las condiciones
que empeoran periódicamente gradualmente
en el sentido de que se cierran más y
más y más espacios y
y la dictadura ha demostrado una
capacidad para
resistir los esfuerzos que se hacen por
parte de algunos países
me refiero a algunos en américa latina y
otros en europa y por supuesto desde
washington
hasta hasta ahora ha resistido
está este conjunto de presiones que se
han intentado de todos que tengo orden y
no ha dado su brazo a torcer y
creo que todavía si se pueden hacer
algunas otras cosas que habría que
intentarlo
porque lo contrario no veo
ninguna estabilidad que en el corto
plazo esa dictadura
acuerde algún tipo de transición hacia
un sistema democrático
a servir que el banco le preguntó usted
habla de hacer otro tipo de cosas de qué
cosas estamos hablando cuáles podrían
ser esos escenarios
a mí me parece que lo que hace falta
hacer es retomar una iniciativa
latinoamericana
en el sentido por ejemplo de crear un
grupo de
países
amigos de la democracia nicaragüense
comprometidos con la democracia
con restauración del sistema democrático
en nicaragua y me parece por ejemplo que
chile podría liderar un esfuerzo un
esfuerzo regional
con aquellas aquellos gobiernos
latinoamericanos que estén dispuestos a
sumarse esto hay que hacerlo por fuera
de la oea y con participación además muy
fuerte muy y muy definida de europa de
canadá y eeuu
y creo que deberían de conseguir o
designar un enviado alguien que pueda
entenderse que pueda viajar a nicaragua
y que pueda
negocia directamente con
representantes de ortega que
probablemente serán sus hijos laureano
en particular que creo que es el más
activo
con el propósito de acordar una un
calendario
si no hay iniciativas de esa naturaleza
creo que lo más probable es que esto
continúe igual es decir si la temática
del statu quo
tiziano en la ciudad de guatemala su
opinión sobre esta propuesta una
iniciativa latinoamericana por fuera de
la oea un país tal vez como chile que
pueda liderar y con una observación y
ayuda de europa como lo ve usted
estoy muy de acuerdo con lo que propone
josé miguel que es un proceso incluso
volver a escuchar de él
pero agregaría un par de elementos más
una
yo creo que todo debería partir de una
claridad mayor sobre lo que son los
objetivos
estratégicos y digamos reales los pasos
concretos incluso que se que se esperan
de parte de ortega para después
empezar un proceso de apertura que
seguramente será paulatina en algún
momento es difícil ver una ruptura como
justamente os anunciábamos de miguel y
de un momento para otro todo el
aparataje montado por parte de ortega y
murillo
venirse para abajo yo creo que en este
esfuerzo sería además importante y eso
es algo que me olvidé mencionado
anteriormente
por lo menos acercarse e interactuar con
algunos de los países que
gozan todavía de cierta apertura porque
son los aliados principales de nicaragua
en la región y me refiero por ejemplo
pues en particular a la cuba que es
básicamente uno de los pocos la habana
es una de las pocas capitales que
todavía
ortega escucha cuyo consejo digamos toma
en consideración sin ponerse digamos en
una actitud de confrontación y es
es notorio o por lo menos hemos
escuchado que incluso en estos países
como
[Música]
venezuela-cuba incluso por parecer china
hay cierta preocupación sobre lo que
ocurre en nicaragua porque efectivamente
ha llegado a un extremo y parte de esta
estrategia para terminar debería ser
también
escuchar básicamente
digamos tomar en consideración la que
son las preocupaciones es precisamente
del gobierno y entre ellas hemos visto
que en el discurso público siempre ha
estado el tema de las sanciones y aunque
no hayan producido el cambio que quizás
esperaban
seguramente han impuesto un costo de
algún tipo en las personalidades
afectadas entonces parte de esta
estrategia debería ser identificar pasos
concretos para que a una apertura
corresponda una medida de levantamiento
de estas sanciones del señor vivanco
mención a tiziano las
sanciones económicas pero tal parece que
no han tenido el efecto
directamente la economía nicaragüense
según análisis que han hecho
especialistas y conocen de cerca la
economía de este país centroamericano
las remesas que llegan principalmente de
eeuu el financiamiento externo y las
exportaciones le han permitido
mantenerse a flote e incluso en mostrar
síntomas de recuperación después de esos
de esos años o meses con tracción
durante la época de las protestas las
sanciones económicas siguen siendo un
punto para obligar una transición
importante seguir las manteniendo esa
opinión sobre ellas
mira para mí ya sean las funciones tanto
las económicas como las personales
por cuestiones de corrupción en fin
tienen que estar constantemente evaluar
siendo evaluadas
y allí los datos empíricos son
fundamentales yo soy enemigo de
aferrarse
con una actitud casi fetichista a esas
esas opciones las sanciones son un
instrumento más de política exterior
para ejercer presión si esta presión no
está dando resultado hay que realizarlas
hay que evaluarlas no podemos caer en
una situación de inmovilismo
donde uno tenga que adopta casi como una
actitud de fe religiosa frente a las
sanciones y en los hechos demuestran que
no están ejerciendo mayor impacto yo
creo que todo debe estar sobre la mesa
en la medida en que se pueda diseñar un
plan que como muy bien dice de tiziano
esté orientado a lograr
resultados
y tangibles resultados concretos
resultados además realistas porque esto
necesariamente es un proceso por
supuesto gradual
quizás habría que determinar por ejemplo
además de la cuestión de las remesas en
fin y si hay algunos
millonarios que hacen negocios en
nicaragua
y que les apoyan al régimen que podrían
ser receptivos o sensibles a algunas
conversaciones de transición democrática
en nicaragua yo creo que la que es de
una evaluación
digamos completa plena integral
de lo que la comunidad internacional
puede hacer porque fiel y lo ayudará con
internacional esta situación no va a
recuerdos claro eso en cuanto al tema
económico también uno de los reclamos
que hacía parte de la población
nicaragüense y también buena parte de la
comunidad internacional era una reforma
o por lo menos mayor claridad en el tema
electoral todo esto a raíz de estas
elecciones presidenciales que le dieron
la oportunidad ortega de quedarse por un
quinto mandato en el poder el gobierno
sandinista ha hecho una reforma la hizo
para esas elecciones que tienen a nivel
regional que están previstas para
finales de este año ahora pues tal
parece que va a ser un proceso electoral
express solamente los candidatos van a
tener cinco días para hacer campaña a
nivel nacional y hay diferentes cambios
lo que ya hace pensar
mal de estas elecciones esto ya es una
alerta declarada desde el principio o
tiziano usted como lo ve de cara a esas
elecciones
regionales para final de año otra alerta
más que puede hacer la comunidad
internacional
efectivamente por como digamos por la
tendencia que estamos viendo de
continuos cierres
y de encarcelamientos
y etcétera y ya estamos hablando incluso
de cancelación de partidos de personas
jurídicas de partidos políticos que hubo
por lo menos en tres en caso de tres
partidos en el año pasado cuya
personalidad jurídica no han sido
devueltas
entonces es impensable que en estas
condiciones pues se puedan dar unos
comicios mínimamente
[Música]
transparentes y justos e incluso creo
que este ejercicio de cerrar todos estos
espacios cívicos
precisamente responda a la intención de
incluso disminuir la capacidad de
monitoreo de estas elecciones porque una
de las cosas en que posiblemente fue
sorprendido el gobierno el año pasado
fue que un grupo de de
representar de la sociedad civil a
través de la organización unas abiertas
pues mandaron básicamente observadores
en incógnito que pudieron estimar no
tenemos datos precisos porque eso
solamente las instituciones de elektra
lo tienen pero estimar una abstención
enorme entonces pudieron efectivamente
contrarrestar la retórica del gobierno
de una participación masiva lo peor para
mí en este contexto es por lo que
escuchado
de todas forma algunos partidos
tradicionales
o representantes incluso de partidos
cuya personalidad jurídica ha sido
cancelada están pensando de todas formas
participar en una estrategia clara sino
digamos el interés
económico y político de mantenerse
digamos en la jugada y quizás obtener
algún favor de vuelta en caso de que
participen por lo que por un gobierno
que el acuerdo entonces reclamar que han
participado varios partidos políticos y
que ha sido un comisión justo claro
josé-miguel aquí hay oportunidad de
ambos bandos el gobierno de ortega puede
afianzarse aún más en en el territorio a
nivel regional hacer un poco más de
presencia en las diferentes regiones
pero en este contexto de unas elecciones
digámoslo bajo represión qué oportunidad
entonces tiene la comunidad
internacional en este escenario estamos
todavía meses para poder tomar acciones
y llevarlas a cabo que pueden hacer
mira yo creo que
está demostrado que ortega y su mujer la
señora murillo
les importa muy poco lo que opinen
el factor estado de la cunita nacional
sobre lo que ocurre en nicaragua y por
eso creo que estuvieron dispuestos a
robarse las elecciones presidenciales y
seguirán exactamente en esa misma tónica
ellos no les importa siquiera generar
una especie de fachada de legitimidad de
dios es
por eso que creo que no no no no merece
demasiado la pena hacer una discusión
multitudinario ni un debate sobre la
democracia electoral nicaragüense porque
ese es un chiste es
simplemente una pantomima
construida por un régimen para seguir
perpetuándose per secula en el poder
entonces este lo que establece es
el reto más la iniciativa a nivel
internacional no abandonar el caso de
nicaragua porque apunta de condenas y
graduales resoluciones
expresando preocupación por lo que
ocurre en nicaragua en la cuestión no va
a mejorar los efectos esto implica un
trabajo de diplomacia de trabajo de
políticas de gran altura de alcaldes el
puñado de gobiernos que no los
encuentras en centroamérica salvo costa
rica por supuesto siempre está costa
rica
pero no nos encuentras no no no no
brillan por su presencia a nivel
regional la región está pasando con
próximo periodo a quién vas a recurrir
andrés manuel lópez obrador es méxico
bolsonaro en brasil que anuncia que se
va a robar las elecciones próximas y si
no le reconocen el triunfo
a priori es porque lo hicieron saudí
entonces este donde están los campeones
latinoamericanos de esta temática hay
muy pocos muy pocos por eso se me ocurre
que chile cuya canciller actual ha
demostrado un gran compromiso por la
causa nicaragüense debería pasar un
poquito más allá de las condenas de las
declaraciones y tomar iniciativas
completas que no están vinculadas al
calendario electoral porque esas
elecciones tal como se robaron las
anteriores también se las van a volver a
robar con la complicidad como dice
tiffany de
grupos o movimientos o partidos locales
internos que están ansiosos de
mantenerse en la vocación ya vamos a
analizar el tema de la democracia a
nivel américa latina es un tema que
dejado para el final del programa para
el cierre usted habla 'josé miguel'
justamente de hacer un poco de consenso
a nivel de los diferentes países o
generar escenarios donde se pueda hablar
sobre el tema de la democracia en
nicaragua y sobre una transición del
poder un escenario puede ser la cumbre
de las américas pero por ejemplo
nicaragua no fue invitado por parte de
eeuu es este tipo de acciones como la
que ha hecho el presidente de byd en una
forma de presionar simplemente no
invitarlo a esta cumbre que ha recibido
todas las críticas por el bajo peso
político que puede llegar a tener
no no yo creo que el propósito de la
cumbre es otro no nunca estuvo no tuvo
esta cumbre el propósito de
armar una una operación diplomática con
el propósito con el objetivo de estas
expresiones sobre nicaragua o venezuela
me parece que era una una precondición
elemental excluir a estas dictaduras
digamos escandalosa como las tres
dictaduras latinoamericanas y estoy de
acuerdo en esa exclusión me parece que
había sido un grave retroceso el
pretender que somos todos iguales
pero pero mira el problema es que la
región no hay donde no hay mucho donde
escoger
y en centroamérica y en sudamérica
y especialmente porque los gigantes de
la región méxico y brasil están
gobernados por populistas autoritarios
que
no son precisamente un buen ejemplo en
el caso de nicaragua
y entonces lo que hay que construir es
una alianza saliendo de esta región
saliendo al marco de la oea que la
verdad que
como agoniza todos los días y por eso
aquí me parece que la figura de un grupo
pequeño
un puñado muy limitado de democracias
latinoamericanas que les importa
nicaragua asociados con europa canadá y
eeuu podría dar lugar a algún tipo de
iniciativas que permitan hacer
interlocución con ella con esta región
tiziano su opinión sobre esta
controversia que ha habido en el marco
de la cumbre de las américas esta
ausencia invitación a venezuela cuba
nicaragua ya apoyamos la posición de
josé-miguel sobre este tema pero ha
generado muchísima controversia le ha
costado incluso a eeuu tomar un
liderazgo claro en esta cumbre y generó
todo tipo de controversias aquí en
américa latina
efectivamente yo creo que
pues evidenció un par de cosas está toda
esta controversia en primer lugar que
bueno la decisión de invitar o no
ciertos países
digamos que es legítimo podría ser
considerada digamos la opción de no
invitar a estos tres países por los
graves situaciones que viven en términos
de estado de derecho y de democracia
pero cuba por ejemplo ya había había
participado en ciertas cumbres este si
hablamos que la democracia debe ser un
principio fundamental para participar en
una en una cumbre de las américas
bueno entonces como comparar con el tema
que estados unidos organizó una cumbre
de las democracias el año pasado y no
invitó a guatemala honduras y el
salvador luego honduras pues eso estuvo
un proceso electoral que fue bastante
exitoso a pesar de que se están teniendo
problemas también allá en términos de
reconocimiento del órgano legislativo o
de la junta directiva del órgano y
legislativo y de ciertas decisiones
políticas pero entonces no han sido
invitadas a en la cumbre de las
democracias pero son democracia
suficiente para participaran a comer las
américas este tipo de controversias y
quizás de
doble pesos domino moral de los
estándares creo que han influido en un
contexto donde se está desarrollando
un sentimiento o una resistencia cada
vez mayor sea digamos una posición
externa es de parte de muchos países se
ha producido de hecho que muchos países
no mandarán a muchos residentes no no
estuvieran entonces posiblemente en
procesos de consulta más extenso con la
región sobre una decisión como ésta
sobre quiere invitar pues hubiera sido
hubiera legitimado más esta decisión que
me quedan pocos minutos para finalizar
el programa 'el para esta parte final
citó iniciando esta pregunta para usted'
y citó unas palabras de jose miguel en
américa américa latina y centroamérica
no hay de dónde escoger en términos de
democracia de política de liderazgo en
qué parte del capítulo esta américa
latina en términos de democracia y de
política con estas dos caras de la
moneda que vemos los liderazgos de
brasil y méxico- muy afectados estamos
al final de este capítulo estamos en
medio del capítulo o se está abriendo un
nuevo capítulo ahora que colombia
enfrenta también elecciones en un par de
semanas como lo ve usted
bueno yo creo que os de miguel es el
mejor posicionado para enfrentar este
tema puesto que mi enfoque es sobre la
región centroamericana que como
justamente mencionábamos de miguel' no
es digamos la más entre las más
positivas en este momento en términos de
situaciones de
digamos de respecto a los
contrapesos democráticos de
independencia de los órganos judiciales
y de digamos separación de poderes más
en general
hay dos procesos electorales que
efectivamente pues llaman la atención
que son de colombia y de brasil
donde posibles giros
digamos podrían efectivamente empezar a
cambiar un panorama regional continental
que de todas forma en los últimos años
hemos visto marcados por una
ideologización en el abordaje de ciertas
crisis la crisis venezolana yo creo que
parte de las razones por la que no se no
se dio o no se se complicó digamos una
el encontrar una
posición a nivel latinoamericano y se
hubiese podido facilitar algún tipo de
resolución precisamente porque se leyó
de éste desde el punto de vista de
izquierda a derecha
y algo parecido ha pasado con nicaragua
por lo tanto pues unos giros posibles
podrían de hecho provocar un cambio
positivo pero veremos qué pasa en
colombia con esta segunda vuelta donde
en cambio parece que se vaya más
consolidando que esta ola quizás
populistas y que ganemos varios países
me quedan pocos minutos para el cierre
de 'josé miguel' en su análisis
digámoslo así sobre este tema un tema
transversal hay crisis institucional en
muchos de los países crisis de confianza
en el sistema por parte de los
ciudadanos muchísimos reclamos por parte
de la ciudadanía de los diferentes
países es una crisis generalizada lo que
estamos viviendo en américa latina con
estos gobiernos inestables que tienen
poca capacidad de acción y poca
capacidad para resolver problemas de
problemas internos digámoslo así
sí yo creo que el fenómeno
lamentablemente es global
y esto
no es sólo algo generalizado en américa
latina por la creciente
desilusión de los ciudadanos que han
llegado a la conclusión que la
alternancia en el poder no alcanza
y que se las han pasado los últimos 30
años alternando y eligiendo y castigando
al partido de gobierno y eligiendo la
posición pero la situación en materia de
corrupción e inseguridad de los
servicios públicos educación las
pensiones
la salud el empleo todo sigue más o
menos igual probablemente mejoran las
cifras pero económicas pero para las
grandes mayorías no hay mayor diferencia
eso es lo que causa condiciones ideales
para el surgimiento de estos caudillos y
listo lamentablemente ninguna democracia
del planeta está vacunado ni siquiera
los eeuu
aquí estamos viviendo un fenómeno donde
hay un procés un déspota que gobernó
durante un tiempo y que parece parece
que se va a postular nuevamente y que
hasta el día de hoy sostiene con el
apoyo de millones de americanos que le
robaron el triunfo presidencial no lo
que ni nombra todos sabemos el tiempo se
trata pero el daño que le hace eso a la
actividad democrática
nada menos que en esta potencia
obviamente y que afecta también nos al
recto la región y el impacto en el resto
del mundo pues a mis dos invitados de
hoy les agradezco por haber hecho este
análisis no solamente de la situación en
nicaragua la situación allí también en
centroamérica y bueno en el resto del
continente sobre la situación
democrática y de nuestras instituciones
en nuestra región les agradezco a los
dos por haber estado en el programa
ustedes puede seguir dejando todas sus
preguntas y comentarios también a través
de las redes sociales y por supuesto
seguir en sintonía de france 24
[Música]